[Music]
loki is the third marvel series to land
on disney plus
and the premiere is just as strange if
not more than the frequently
mind-bending wand division
and like wandavision there are some fun
easter eggs tucked away for marvel fans
to find
when episode 1 of loki kicks off a brief
recap of the events leading up to the
series plays out
after loki is captured at the finale of
the avengers we see him escorted by the
superhero team to the bottom floor of
avengers tower
as we saw in avengers end game a
disgruntled hulk
causes a future tony stark to drop a
briefcase containing the tesseract which
then bounces in front of loki's feet
the trickster grabs the cube and
vanishes disrupting the entire time
heist
we find out that this portal's other end
was in the gobi desert in mongolia where
loki drops out of the sky
his head sticks out of the sand as he
lays on his back the desert's landscape
partly covering his green and gold garb
while it's a brief moment in the
episode's intro it's also a major
callback to the mcu property that
started it all
iron man when tony escapes from his
captors in that film he flies off into
the sky but he comes crashing down into
the desert sand after his home-brewed
suit
malfunctions breaking apart into
hundreds of pieces
and leaving him dazed on the ground the
shot with loki is a nice nod to the
first iron man and a pleasant parallel
that depicts the aftermath of two men
who have just escaped capture
after loki is captured by the tva he's
taken to their headquarters he signs
some paperwork
walks through a temporal aura detector
and then takes a number as he waits to
see a judge for his crimes against the
timeline
while waiting he's treated to an
educational video produced by the tva to
explain to variants why they've been
captured
hosted by tva mascot miss minutes the
video goes into detail about the
creation of the tva and how the
timekeepers monitor the time stream
miss minutes then explains that when
variants veer off their predetermined
course
stepping off your path created a nexus
event
which left unchecked could branch off
into madness
leading to another multiversal war
this isn't the first time we've heard
the word nexus in the marvel cinematic
universe
and the last time wasn't long before
loki one of the six one division
commercials
seen during the series show within a
show is an advertisement for nexus
antidepressants
nexus because the world doesn't revolve
around you
or does it nexus will be a significant
word and concept moving forward in the
mcu as evidenced by the title of the dr
strange sequel dr strange and the
multiverse of madness which is being
written by loki head writer michael
waldron
in one division the nexus drug was being
advertised as a medicine for wanda
maximoff's grief and anger and also a
reference to her role as a nexus being
loki is poised to further explore what
the term means in the mcu
when loki is apprehended in the gobi
desert several tva officers arrive
through a portal to capture him
while it's not specifically stated who
they are or what their title is
these guards seem to be a nod to marvel
comics minutemen based on their purpose
and uniforms
first appearing in fantastic four number
352
the minutemen are charged with policing
the time stream as these tva guards
serve the same sort of purpose
their appearance is a nice easter egg in
the marvel comics the men and men are
actually robots not human beings as they
appear to be in loki
however it should be noted that at the
beginning of episode 1 a tva worker asks
loki to clarify that he is not
a fully robotic being do a lot of people
not know if they're robots
it's probably nothing more than a
throwaway gag but marvel is nothing if
not tricky
who knows the guards or minutemen could
actually be artificial
sure owen wilson's agent mobius is a bit
of a time cop
but that's not why he's sporting that
mustache in the comics agent mobius's
look was based on the late mark grunwald
a prolific marvel comics writer and
editor known for being marvel's resident
continuity expert until his untimely
death at age 43 from a heart attack
so it makes sense that the live-action
mobius would keep the stash from the
comics and bring this sweet homage to a
marvel legend into the mcu
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
loki are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one